- Hey, everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
this is the #podSessions.
This our eighth edition of this format
where I bring in three individuals
and we shoot the shit
about different things,
find out what they're obsessed about,
talk a little bit about
marketing and branding,
talk a little bit about their worlds,
and so I'm very excited
to have three individuals here,
they're all very attractive,
so if you're listening
on the podcast and not
watching the YouTube,
you've made a huge mistake.
And I'm gonna let them
all introduce themselves,
so why don't we start with
the lovely lady to my left.
- Thank you, my name is Charly Arnolt,
known in the WWE world as Charly Caruso.
- Yes.
- I am an announcer for
WWE, I do the interviews
on Monday Night Raw and I'm a studio host
for the WWE network.
- Awesome, we'll get
into how that happened.
Thanks for being here today,
glad you're here.
- Yeah, absolutely,
thank you for having me.
- Of course.
- I'm Erik Jones, I
drive the number 20 car
in in the Cup Series for Joe Gibbs.
- And how long have you
been in the Cup Series?
- This is my second year.
- Okay, and how old are you?
- 22.
- You know, just I did a# AskGaryVee show
with Kyle Busch and we
were talking a little bit
about how everybody's younger in the game.
So I'm excited to get into
that, and where were you born,
where did you grow up?
- Michigan.
- Michigan, awesome, cool.
Thanks for being here.
And the Michigan race is coming up, right?
- Yeah, next week, not
this weekend, next weekend.
So yeah.
- Do you feel extra
pressure when you're there?
- Not extra pressure, but
I'd like to win there.
- You'd like your homies from like
grade school come through?
Yeah, we'll get into that in a minute.
- I'm Ty Dillon, I
drive the 13 GEICO Chevy
in the Monster Energy Cup Series.
I'm 26 and we are both rookies together.
So it's our second
season in the Cup Series.
- Fantastic, thanks for being here.
And you're, you know, I know from afar,
just like looking at my social like,
you've been like very good
at adapting to the new world.
Is that a big passion of yours?
- Yeah, and it started from you, honestly.
I had my first daughter this
off season, so sitting around
with her when she's a little baby,
I was sittin' on my phone.
My barber actually told
me, he was like, hey,
you gotta check out Gary
Vee, you've got that kind of
attitude just like him, you've
gotta check out his content.
That spurred me into, I bought,
okay, first thing I did,
I don't know why, but first
thing I did was I bought
two tickets to South by
Southwest, knowing that I wanted
to get a videographer to start capturing
content of what I liked.
Then I met Joseph, put out
an Instagram video, said hey,
and this is kind of from
your playbook too, saying,
hey, anybody young, wants
to go out and video my life
and see what I do and
capture content for me
for a full year and do, I think
I said, 36 events with me,
we're going to go and have some fun.
Did that, started a vlog
series, and it's just kind of
gone from there and it's been huge for me
in my career and what I'm doing.
- It matters.
Okay, what I want to do now
is we'll go back around,
Charly we'll start with you,
this is my favorite part,
this is probably why I did
this show, because I think
this is what I did in real
life at dinners with friends
and in business, and it's my
favorite part of the show.
I want to know what you're
currently obsessed with.
Now this can be something
that's going on in NASCAR
or truck series or the
WWE, but I also think it's
super interesting if it's
like refinding, you know,
Trix cereal, or like a
new shampoo, or like,
you've found your buddy from third grade
and you're on a text chain.
Like right now, random as shit,
what are you obsessed with Charly?
- I'm obsessed with saying yes right now.
I started a new kick a few
weeks ago where I say yes
to pretty much anything
and it's kind of been,
it's been a great time.
I kind of got into a
routine where it was like,
my life got very routine
and you know, I'd come home
from work, I'd watch some Netflix, I would
eat my meal prepped
dinners, and I just, it got
kind of boring and I was
like, what's going on here?
Why am I living such
a complacent lifestyle
when I'm in one of the
greatest cities in the world
and I have so many
opportunities at my fingertips
and a friend had mentioned
to me that she had started
saying yes to more and I
was like, you know what,
I'm going to try that
and I have been so busy
this summer now with just so many
different types of things.
I've met so many people
and it's all because I've
started saying yes to things.
- I love that.
I'm such a, I have a lot of
content on yes when it comes to
business, but when it
comes to life that makes
so much sense, good for you.
What's the most ridiculous
thing you've done
in your yes journey?
- Oh, um, let's see, I
just traveled to Ibiza
a few weeks ago.
It was a trip I've wanted
to take for so long.
- That sounds terrible.
- It was a blast.
- Oh I know it was a blast.
- I said yes to a lot of things
when I was there as well,
which also led to me having
a blast, but I was there
for two and a half days.
- That's about a day and a half too much.
- Let's do it, and it was so much fun.
I met a ton of cool people who
live in New York who I have
already connected with
since I've been back
and it's been great.
- I love it, good for you.
What are you obsessed with, my man?
- Right now, motorcycles.
- Interesting, for a lot
of us who did not grow up
in racing or car culture, it
seems that's an easy jump,
but is this a new thing for you, like you
were never into them?
- Yes, yeah it's new.
- Because everyone around
you's like oh fuck,
that's dangerous shit.
- Yeah, everybody says
it's a very bad idea.
- There's something so
weird, like, motorcycles
genuinely make, like the math,
I like things that are logical.
I'm very fascinated that
more people will die
from texting and driving tomorrow
than from terrorism in the
next five years in America
yet the delta of how we
talk about it, right.
But motorcycles a son
of a bitch, like people
really get fucked up on motorcycles.
The other one I love is
like hippos and sharks.
Like hippos kill so many
fucking people and yet
we love hippos because
of Hungry Hungry Hippos
and they're so cute.
And sharks, we're scared
shitless and they kill
like eight people a year.
So why'd you get into it?
- I want one, I mean, number one.
- Like what, you saw
some dude on Instagram
on a motorcycle, like, it's time?
Or did you watch a movie
or did your buddy tell you?
- No, I wanted a
motorcycle instead of a car
when I was 16, and I had saved
up my own money to buy a car
but that got shut down very quickly--
- Your own motorcycle you mean.
- Yes.
- When you were 16 you
saved up the money to buy
your own motorcycle and
you mom was like fuck you.
- Yeah, so I never got the motorcycle.
- So you're 22 now and
might as well do it?
- It might have to wait.
- Why, like your team doesn't want you to?
- I don't think they'd appreciate it.
- I get it, right?
You know, it's funny, my
brother AJ and I started
Vayner Sports, we're only
repping football players,
but a lot of guys, a lot of
teams want motorcycle clauses,
literally motorcycle clauses.
- Well Ben Roethlisberger, remember?
- I do, I do.
What football team do you like?
- Lions.
- Man, I am so fucking proud of you.
I swear to God I was sitting
like a cobra in the grass
right now, like if this
fucking dude from Michigan
doesn't say Lions, because
he wasn't supporting
the local team because they've sucked shit
his whole life, I'm not
going to like him as much.
Now I like you twice as
much as 30 seconds ago.
- Yeah, I like all the Detroit teams.
- I don't know if you know
this, but Monday night opener
this year, Jets Lions.
- Really, I didn't know that.
- Yes, I did because I love the Jets
more than I love everything.
- Well you're sticking with the team too.
- 100, first of all it's
a ridiculously terrible
Monday night game, Jets
Lions, I have not figured out
what the NFL was thinking.
- That's how they're kicking it off.
- It can only go up from
there though, right?
- September 17th, you're
done with the season.
- Is that here?
- It'll be in Detroit.
- All right, I'll be home.
- Do you wanna go to the game with me?
- Yeah, I'll go to the game.
- We're done.
- I love the Lions, I go
to a lot of the games.
- That's going to be a funny
picture on social media.
Everybody's like, holy
shit, that happened?
- That's awesome.
Me, I've got a couple things.
Obviously, my daughter, so
watching her grow has been
awesome to me.
- Crazy, right?
- Amazing.
- First one, first year, is just nuts.
- [Ty] It's blown my mind.
- You're scared shitless, right?
- [Ty] Definitely, every day, yeah.
- I remember when my daughter
was born, I'd come home
late from work, and
like, 19 times, I'm like,
out of nowhere, she's not
breathing, I just have to go.
I know she's not
breathing, she's gonna die.
- If they're not crying
you're more worried.
- Yeah, so that's been a
lot of fun, big life change.
- Yeah, that's the first
one, second one is football.
- I mean, don't play to the
crowd, tell me something weird.
- It's going to sound general
at first, but it's going
to get real specific.
So football.
- American football?
- American football, I'm a die
hard Carolina Panthers fan,
born and raised in North
Carolina, but to the point
where I will watch, break
down every film of every game
throughout the season.
- Because that's what you
do for your own sport,
right, like you watch--
- Sort of, yeah, getting
prepared and everything.
But I have dreams one day,
after this sport, of being
the general manager of a
football team or owning a team.
I don't think I want to
own, I think I want to
run personnel, so I go in and
make notes of every practice,
practice things that I would
see different, do different.
- We have a kid we represent
name Kyle Allen who is
right now trying to make the
team as the third quarterback,
who I think is really
a diamond in the rough.
When he was 17 people thought
he was going to go number
one overall in this draft.
He went undrafted and Carolina
signed him UDFA, but it was
really unbelievable to
like do the homework
on the circumstances of what happened
to him at Texas A&M and Houston.
It's got the narrative to really work out.
I'm hoping he sticks in Carolina.
- He came in after Manziel, right?
- Yeah, but then another
kid the following--
I grew up in the northeast
where college football was nothing.
For me it was the NFL,
the NBA, WWF in my day.
But I had no idea how
much the boosters really
drove shit in college football.
Texas A&M is super political,
super fascinating stuff.
- I just saw Kyle because
I went and watched
training camp live on Monday.
- You're a hardcore Panthers fan.
- I'm hardcore, same thing with baseball.
I love the analytics of baseball, I study.
- Who are you a fan of in baseball?
- Atlanta Braves, the closest one.
There's been talk of
Charlotte getting a team,
that's right near our house.
So if that happened I would just--
- You'd lose your shit.
- It would be insane.
I don't know what I'd do with my career
that I've got going now in NASCAR
but man it would be big.
My wife wouldn't like it.
- Let's go into origin stories.
Let's paint a picture for everybody.
Let's do a two or three
minute, four minute,
who are you, where were you born,
how'd you get into what you're into,
what are you into, blah blah blah.
- All right, I was born
in Indianapolis, Indiana,
so I've been around racing
a good portion of my life.
It's not NASCAR but I've
been going to Indy 500
my whole life and I went
on to work in television.
I went to American University,
I always knew I wanted
to work in television.
Never knew exactly which
path I wanted to take
but I always said I wanted
to be the next Oprah,
that was always my big
thing when I was growing up
and someone actually just
commented on my photo today like,
Charly or Oprah, and I
was like, best compliment
I've ever gotten in my
life and of course now
it's on an Instagram photo.
- Do you want to hear a really fun fact?
- [Charly] Yeah.
- You should go look at Oprah's
first Instagram photo ever.
- Really.
- I'll just leave it at that, keep going.
- So I graduated with a
Broadcast Journalism degree
from American.
- Were you out of control in college
or were you like super focused.
- I was pretty focused.
I was in a sorority, and
we had our parties here,
you know like Chi Omegas
do not drink, do not drink.
Whatever, we drank.
Honestly I had a good
time but I'm super type A,
to a fault sometimes.
3.95 GPA graduated with.
- Like that boy's cute but
I'm gonna be the next Oprah,
fuck you Johnny.
- I tried to skip class once
in college, I freaked out,
I ran to class, no
attendance was even taken.
That's how I was.
Went to Huntington, West
Virginia for my first job,
one man band reporter,
carried all my shit with me,
went and interviewed
people about overdosing
on bath salts, it was
very interesting terrain
in West Virginia.
Went on to Kansas City, Missouri
still reporting news there,
went back to Indianapolis,
my home town, that's when
I got into sports, sports
anchor, sports reporter.
And then from there, WWE saw
my work, asked me to audition.
- On a local network?
- Yeah, I was working for
the FOX station there.
- Doing sports reporter.
- Yeah.
- Like the Colts are playing
the Browns this weekend.
- Exactly.
- Okay.
- And WWE, actually the way
it happened, I was back stage
at SmackDown, it was in
Indianapolis, and I ran into
the head of talent relations,
his name was Mark Corono.
At this point my contract
with Indianapolis had
just expired, I didn't want to renew it.
I said, "Hey, I recoginize you
from the show Total Divas,"
which is that reality show,
I said, "I'm a sports caster,
"would you mind taking a look at my work?"
He said, sure, didn't
really follow up with me,
so I reached out again a few months later.
He's like, you're good, I like you,
I'm going to pass this along.
So he passed it along to Michael Cole,
who I know you know who he is,
and from there they had me come audition,
and the rest is history, here I am.
- So did you grow up
watching wrestling at all?
- I was a fan at the
beginning of middle school,
so sixth, seventh grade,
height of the Attitude Era.
- Got it, so the Stone Cold,
like, everybody cared--
- Everybody loved it.
- So who were your favorites
then, like Mankind?
- The Rock, I'm still
obsessed with The Rock.
Like I secretly--
- Because he's secretly Oprah.
- Oh he's great.
- You know The Rock is
actually Oprah, right?
- Oh yeah, he's fantastic,
so still love him.
- Yeah, he's amazing.
What's your story brother?
Lions fan from the get.
- Yeah, Lions fan from the start.
I have kind of an odd
story for racing, at least,
from where I'm at.
I started when I was seven,
so I started very young in go-karts.
I started moving up through
the ranks after that.
- Why did that happen?
- Why did I start racing?
- Was your family into it
or did you stumble into it?
- No, I more so stumbled into it.
My family never raced, but
I was always a fan of cars.
My mom actually got me into
it, got me started in it.
- What, she wanted you out of the house?
- I think so, I wasn't
good at any other sports
and I didn't have any other hobbies.
- She's like, get the fuck out of here.
- Like, go do this instead.
- Did it click right away?
- Like was I good right
away, or did I like it?
- How about both?
- Immediately I liked it
right away, I loved it.
And I guess I was decent,
we won some races.
From there I started moving
up into some lower stuff
outside of NASCAR, late
models, they call them,
around that area.
I was racing there until I was about 16
and I got an opportunity,
actually from Kyle.
I was racing against him and he came down
and raced one of those races.
You know there's no rules
in racing, you can go back,
run whatever race you want.
- Why do guys do that?
Is it to work on something?
Almost like a triple A thing
or giving love to the community,
or it's a mix of many things?
- That type of race you're
running is very different
car than NASCAR.
- Sometimes they miss it and like it?
- I think it's kind of a
respect back to the sport
because it's still not easy
to go back and beat those guys
who run that car every single
weekend at that same track.
- That makes sense.
- And it's a fun thing too
because it gets back
to your initial roots.
- So when Kyle comes and
visits and he's already
in the big series, like
is that fun, you're like
oh shit, yeah, I wanna kill him.
- Yeah, it's a big deal, you want to win.
- It's like when Kershaw gets
hurt and does a triple A start
in New Mexico and
everyone's like holy shit.
I love that, I love that
part of triple A baseball
or double A baseball, like
when it's a small town
or what have you, and a big
league star has to come through
just for a rehab start.
So, what, you raced in a race with him
and he just saw the talent?
- We raced at the end and
I ended up beating him
in that race and he
gave me an opportunity,
that was 2012, so in
2013 to drive his truck,
he has a truck team there.
I started racing for him
and we won a race in 2013
and he gave me more
opportunities and we kept winning
and just moved into a role
over at Joe Gibbs Racing after that.
I mean, there's a lot to
it, I could talk about it--
- I'm sure, but the origin
story is meeting him in a race
in that series opened up
doors, you kept performing,
you're on the big show.
And how is the big show?
- It's tough, I mean, it's hard.
It's fun, I love it, but it's tough.
- Because the transition
to the car is so different?
- The car and the competition.
The competition level is
very very high in Cup.
I mean, just everybody is really good.
From 1st to 40th, everybody's pretty good.
The thing about cup is at
one point I would say--
- Have you won a race there yet?
- One, yeah, just this year.
- Did you fucking freak your shit?
- I did, yeah, I was losin' it.
- Was that crazy?
- Oh yeah, it was nuts.
- Was that the goal this year, like,
I gotta get a win on the board?
- Yeah, for me.
I wanted to last year.
We had an opportunity to
win last year a couple times
and we didn't really execute on it.
Kyle actually spoiled one of them for me.
- He seems like a real dick.
I love it, I love how
competitive he is, actually.
- He came up and drove by
me with about 50 laps to go,
just kind of, deuces--
- Peace out.
- Yeah, I ran second.
Yeah, I mean, that's a big
goal there, to get a win.
You want to be a winner there, at the Cup.
- Good for you, what other
interests do you have,
outside of motorcycles and
cars, out side of that niche,
what else, what grabs at
you, cooking, TV shows?
- I wish I was into cooking,
I wish I was good at it.
I love to golf, golf, scuba
dive, I'm a scuba diver,
I haven't been as much
but I like to scuba dive.
I'm a big outdoors fan, I love
being outside doing whatever.
- Love it, my man?
- For me, I grew up in a racing family.
My grandfather is Richard
Childress, who owned
Dale Earnhardt's number three car,
so he's won seven championships
with Dale Earnhardt and then championships
through the Xfinity Series.
- You grew up in, for a
lot of people listening
who don't know the sport, you
kind of grew up in royalty,
not even like in a family.
That must be stupid pressure.
- Somewhat, but honestly,
my grandfather, my parents,
my dad raced also, they
never pushed it on us.
I wanted to play middle
linebacker in football,
that's what I wanted to do.
- And then you realized, oh fuck.
- I'm too small.
- What year was that,
fourth grade, seventh grade?
- Junior PeeWee, I was going
to pee wee football and
the hits were getting
harder, I was like 13.
- You're like, why is
this guy running over me?
- Yeah, I was like 13 and
I was fortunate enough to
have a grandfather that
I could call and say
hey, I wanna try racing,
and I'd seen kids our age
running around a track at
Charlotte Motor Speedway,
it's inside of the track,
it's a quarter mile.
From that day, got in a
car for the first time,
it's like whatever's in
his blood, my dad's blood,
it clicked in.
- Really.
- I remember leaving the
track that day and I knew
I loved what I just did
and my grandfather and my
dad and mom all had a conversation
with my brother and I,
we started at the same time,
he was 15 and I was 13.
I made the call, he might
say it, but I made the call
to get us our first test.
We left the track and they
said, If this is what you guys
wanna do, you're gonna commit to it.
If you really feel like you
wanna do this, we'll commit
and we'll try to make it
happen and you guys can race
as much as you want, but you're
going to commit to doing it
and do it right.
- You can't be half pregnant.
- Yeah, exactly, and at
that time, at 13, I was like
for sure, I'm in, I'm gonna
do it, I'm gonna be great,
and I committed, we
committed, and I ran 70 to 80
races a year, leaving school
on Thursdays and Fridays,
doing all my homework
Sunday night, getting home
Sunday night, even when
I was 16 in high school,
I would go off, my dad
would be at the race track
helping our cup teams, I
would be racing a dirt car
out in the midwest,
drive home, do homework,
then once I got in high school
I did more one on one classes.
I really just committed
my life to racing and was
successful all the way up through.
And you get the haters that
say because it's your family,
but I was able to be successful.
You don't get to the Cup
Series just off of being
helped the whole way, you don't last.
But now I made it to the Cup Series,
I won in the Truck Series, my
first year I won two races.
I beat Kyle for my first
win, which was huge.
I look up to his talent.
He's our best driver
in the sport right now,
I feel like talent wise.
I beat him for my first win.
- Who is this Truex guy
that I just found out about,
who's from Jersey, he's
got like a wrestling name.
That's literally what I was
thinking of, I mean, Truex.
- He's tearing it up these last few years.
- What's going on with these
three guys, it sounds like
have won like almost every
fucking race this year?
- They're dominating for sure.
- Is everybody else pissed?
- Yeah, pretty much.
(laughing)
So, one early in the Xfinity
Series, one in Indianapolis,
was my first win there, to
get a win at the Brickyard
was huge, just so much history.
Now my second year in
Cup Series I'm not racing
for my grandfather's team,
I'd raced for his team
my whole career.
- Why did that happen?
- Just because I ran Xfinity
three years and he had
drivers on contracts for his
jobs and sponsor obilgations
and I felt like I was ready--
- That's cool.
- To make the next level,
and the team was actually--
- That says a lot about
everybody in that story.
- Yeah, it's been really awesome for me.
The team is still a technical
alliance so we share
information with my
grandfather's team, but we are
our own separate entity still.
All the cars come out of a different shop
that's actually an hour away.
So I've been racing for them
for two years and we had
their most successful season
last year in my rookie season
statistic wise across the
board and we're really trying
to build a program.
It's up and down, like you
said, going from Truck Series,
I won and was in my rookie
year was battling for a
championship all the way
down to the last race
and got wrecked by a good
friend now, but Kyle Larson,
making his first or second
start in the Truck Series,
he wrecked me and I lost the championship.
- So you hated his face.
- For a while.
- Like two years?
- Yeah, about two years,
and then I got to know him
a little bit better.
Same thing, Xfinity Series,
was battling for championships
and now in the Cup Series
it's like taking three steps
and it's so much tougher but
we're battling it, I feel like.
- What's been your best results so far?
- Sixth this year, the race
he won I finished sixth.
I actually filled in for
Tony Stewart three years ago
when he had a back injury and
finished sixth in his car.
He started the race, he
got out, I got in the car
and finished sixth.
- Really, I didn't know that happened.
- That doesn't count.
- Unofficially, I didn't
get the finish for that.
- He does?
- He gets sixth place.
- Really, the person that
starts, that's interesting.
- I crossed the line, finished sixth.
- I heard you loud and
clear, I understood.
- I wish the statistics were.
- Yeah, I get it.
- No but it's been an awesome
career, I've just been trying
to make the most out of
this moment in my life.
- With the vlogging and the show.
- With everything, yeah, it
found me here today, which is,
as you can tell, I'm so excited,
this is really cool for me.
- I appreciate that, I'm flattered.
Actually, let's make that transition.
I know that Tyler got
ahold of you and your team
and so I'm glad you're here.
For you Charly, how do you
think about social, Instagram,
what do you use, what do you
like, how much of an impact
does it have, what's good
about it, what's bad about it?
- I mean, there's such a wide spectrum
from what's good about it
to what's terrible about it,
in my opinion, but it's
one of those things
that's not going anywhere,
it's getting bigger and bigger
as the days go by so I'm
just trying to embrace it
as much as I can.
I mean, as far as building--
- Take me back to Type A you,
we don't drink we don't drink.
Were you a Facebook girl back then?
What years, you know, what
did you use back then,
anything, nothing?
- Well, yeah I mean I was--
- Did you grow up on MySpace as a kid?
- MySpace, I had the top eight.
- Were you strategic about your top eight?
- Oh absolutely, you did something wrong,
you were outta there.
- When you would drop somebody, like Carol
from science class, from your
top eight, and you came to
school that day, because I was an old man
by the time MySpace came.
- Yeah, it made a difference.
- For you youngsters.
- [Charly] Avoid eye contact.
- Was that a real thing?
- Oh yeah, absolutely,
it was very much like disowning a friend.
- I think somebody needs to bring back
the top eight dynamic.
I've actually been having
this weird feeling,
this just not a dream,
not a daydream, but this
overall feeling that we're on the,
I feel like there's these
two girls somewhere like
in the suburbs of Denver
working on an app.
I can feel it, you know, like the force,
I feel like it's Star Wars.
I feel like I'm so in tune
with the social media zeitgeist
that I think we're on the
verge of something coming out.
And now I'm going to try
to use my powers to make
those kids decide to make it
more about top eight dynamics.
- We can't offend anybody any more.
- Do we want that now,
everyone's so sensitive.
- Is that where you're going with this?
- I'm just saying--
- I'm not going to go
overly political, but you
believe even in this short
10, 12, 15 year window,
that the top eight dynamic
would not play in the current
state of like people
offended about everything,
about everything about everything.
- Yeah.
- That's interesting.
I think the country's very
split now on the defending.
To me, I'm unbelievably
socially liberal and I think
everybody should love
everybody, but I will say,
like eighth place trophies
is the bane of my existence.
The think that I've loved about,
the thing I've loved so far
talking about all of this
energy of competitiveness
and things of that nature,
is this, I don't understand
how people want to put
their kids in situations
where there aren't winning and losing.
You fundamentally don't
set them up for success.
They're like, finished.
- Yeah, my dad never let me win.
- Anything.
- No.
- I'm like destroying my six
year old son in everything.
The whole family is bent
out of shape and I'm like,
he's going to be a loser otherwise.
I genuinely believe that.
- Yeah, remember there was
that big debacle over
the participation awards.
Remember, when was that, a few years ago?
- Good news, I've had
that as a macro thesis
for the last 20 years.
I also think school does that a lot.
I actually think, back to being
Type A, like student life,
there's been this enormous
push on being an entrepreneur,
which I'm very in, and I
failed in school for a reason.
Winning in school is an incredible skill.
You figure out the system and you play it.
The problem is, much like the
shift from truck to the cup,
being an entrepreneur is
literally like swimming
versus cooking, to being good at school.
They're completely different.
I think that fake environments,
is what I call them,
are very very very dangerous.
I mean, as a matter of fact,
you're probably successful
because your family over
corrected by not putting you
in a fake environment
because of the lineage,
and the last name, like that's
the only way you could be
this happy and successful.
- Yeah, I almost over corrected,
I was working on my car.
At certain levels I had smaller
teams than other people.
- You had to, you had to, you had to.
- And I probably had more
backing in capability growing up.
- Because this dude coming up who came out
of left field from a different place
with not that background,
you can't help it as a human, you're
going to deploy that
cynicism, and you're going to,
if you're the outsider not
with it, that's the chip.
And if you're in it you've
got the reverse is the chip.
- [Ty] It's definitely the reverse.
- 100%
- Then you wanna shove it
in everybody's face when--
- Like, the I told you so,
is the most fucking delicious flavor ever.
I'm obsessed with it. Do
you feel like that now?
Like you've clearly, you're
on a pretty big stage now
you've been talking shit your whole life
with your friends, like
I'm gonna be on TV,
like clearly some of
them smiled in your face
but didn't think so.
Do you love coming back to Indy
like fuck you mother fucker?
- You know what, I
personally don't because
I always knew I was gonna be successful.
- And you didn't give
a fuck what Karen said.
- No, I didn't care
about Karen, fuck Karen.
- You hate Karen.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I always knew I
was going to be successful
whatever path I took.
- Why?
- I just don't accept failure.
I'm telling you, when I say I'm Type A,
it's a beautiful thing because it makes it
so that I will never
accept failure as even
a remote possibility.
- How do you make, what's the fine line
between determination and delusion?
- I don't know, I think
if you, I don't think
you can be delusional.
I mean, if you're willing
to put the work in--
- Well if you've ever
watched American Idol,
but here's what happens, "Hi
Simon, I'm the next Beyonce."
Wow, very exciting, please sing.
Bah, that's delusion.
- Okay, right, right.
- Like these guys came
up with guys driving,
their homies at 16, they're
fucking stealing a beer
from 7-11 after a race,
and Rick looks at them like
motherfucker I'm going
to be there one day,
and they're, through
their heads, they're like,
I know this, you have no shot.
That's delusion.
- True, true, I stand corrected.
- And by the way, I'll be honest with you,
it was funny to hear
you pause a little bit,
I was literally laughing
really fast in my head.
I'm like, I'm glad nobody's
ever asked me that question
because I don't know either.
It's super hard to think about.
It seems like an incredible fine line.
- It's intuition, I feel
like it's more intuition
whether you know you can
keep going and you know
that you don't want to give up
because you know you've got it.
- It's like being honest with yourself.
- I mean, it's delusional
for me to say I'm going to go
on American Idol and even
have a chance at winning
because I am an awful
singer, I am the worst.
- I'm really bad too.
- I'm a great singer.
- What?
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
- No, on a very serious note,
because you've kind of got
the joke face right now,
do you think you can
sing a little bit?
- No.
- Yeah, I saw the joke face.
- I do karaoke, I love karaoke.
- What's your go-to karaoke song?
- Should Have Been A Cowboy.
- That's exactly what I
thought you were going to say.
- I love Toby Keith.
- But if you have a skill set
that you know you're good at
and you push in that direction.
- Do you have siblings?
- No.
- Wow, and what kind of
mom and dad situation
did you have, the best?
- I mean, yes, my mother,
still to this day,
she calls me so many times a day.
I'm like, Mom, we've already
talked three times today,
I love you but there's
nothing left to say today,
let's shut this down.
My mother was always the doting,
like everything I did was perfect.
- She was the cheerleader.
- Yes
- Okay, Dad?
- Dad was the opposite and still is,
like he will not tell
me what I want to hear.
- It's interesting, and I
had this, do you think the
polar opposites of how they
did it, in that pulling,
you were able to develop the strength,
make the diamonds from that pressure?
- Yeah, I think so because--
- Because you had both behaviors.
- If you have just one
I think it can push you
in a certain direction but
if you have both it's--
- Thoughts on that?
- My mom was definitely
the cheerleader, always
had the back of her babies and
my dad was on the other side
like no, hell no, make him do this right,
he's gotta do it right.
I think it carved me a perfect
path to be who I am now.
- What about for you?
- They're both pretty hard
on me, I was really not
a good kid though, I was not a good kid.
- What, you were a straight dick?
- I mean, yeah, looking
back, yeah, pretty much.
- Why?
- I wouldn't want to deal with me, why?
- Well yes you do, let's
get into psycho class here.
Like what was happening,
you were mad at the world,
or you thought it was funny?
- Well, I thought I was very funny.
I thought I was very
funny and I hated school.
And that was yeah, I was
always in trouble in school.
- And what, you thought you
were funny and you found
one or two other fucking
dick faces and you guys
created a crew?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I told you I'd
figure it out in one second,
it's just fucking text book.
- We were real smart,
a lot of talking back
in class, at home, to everyone.
- And where are those homies now?
- I don't hang out with
them, I don't know.
I haven't seen them in a long time.
- BuWill they show up to
the Michigan race though
and have a sign like, yo fuckface?
- Oh yeah, some of them will,
I still talk to some of them
sometimes, we keep in touch.
- I have the same thing going on.
Okay so back to social, what do you love?
- Social media, I love it
because you can connect
with so many different types
of people, whether it's
in your industry or otherwise.
I just started getting more into fitness.
I just got my personal
training certification
a few weeks ago.
It's another area I want
to pursue and hopefully--
- Has it run through your mind to wrestle?
Like being around it, I mean, you come in,
I heard your background,
you're a sportscaster.
At one point you're thinking Cole, Ross,
even McMahon, Jesse The
Body Ventura used to be
very very very good at the announcer game.
You come in thinking about those things,
and who else knows what you were thinking,
like SportsCenter, or
whatever you were thinking,
but being in the culture
of it, like you guys
fucking work hard.
You guys are on the road a lot.
Has it crossed your mind to wrestle?
- I mean, I'd be lying
if I said that it didn't.
- I knew it.
- However--
- This is back to the linebacker thing.
The thing about wrestling
that's interesting,
back to a Rey Mysterio Jr or others,
like you may not have the
size but you can find,
figure a, like Mike
from fucking Real World,
it just feels achievableish kinda.
- So it's not delusional.
- It's very delusional.
- I was just wondering.
- But to your point, it's a great jump in,
I think the easiest way to get delusional,
is to be suffocated in the culture of.
If you're there, you're
just like, you know,
you're just in the bubble, right?
- Yeah, and it looks easy.
- I think NASCAR makes me
laugh because I know dudes,
like, unlike football or
other things, it's driving,
we do it, and so for a
lot of people they don't
play that sport any more, they only did it
a long time ago, but
they're still driving,
and I'm sure all of these idiots
think that they can do it.
- Plus, anybody can pick
up a set of golf clubs
and know they're not Tiger Woods, right?
You can't just go hop in
a car and try to race.
- Yeah, I think the worst
version of it in culture
right now, to be honest, is
my game, entrepreneurship.
I mean, every single Instagram
photo is entrepreneur.
Because, they fucking
came up with a brand name
for T-shirts and made 15
T-shirts and think they are
fucking going to build a
trillion dollar empire.
I mean, the entrepreneur
delusion is really tough
because unlike NASCAR, or
being on TV, or other sports,
nobody really knows what's happening.
All those things are front facing.
With entrepreneurship you're like,
yeah, I'm working on my thing,
so you can't keep score.
You don't see it until the end,
which is why it's super dangerous.
So anyway, sorry, we keep running around.
So you love that you can connect.
- It's great to connect because
not being in that world,
it's not like I've worked
my way up in that world,
where I met people along the way.
Now I can just find people and
connect with them instantly
which is really cool.
So I love that, I love being
able to build my platform
and get exposure and being
able to build my brand in the
different sectors that I'm
interested in, so I really
enjoy social media for those reasons.
- What don't you like?
- I don't like the fact that
everyone is getting very,
everyone's getting stupider.
Communication is suffering
so much where like,
you'll be in a room with
your friends and you're
all on your phones and I'll notice--
- Hold on hold on, let's talk about this
because I have a very unique
point of view on this.
As someone who's older than you three,
let me tell you what friends
did in 1999 when they
were all in a room.
We watched fucking TV.
Like, friends aren't supposed
to be talking to each other
every fucking second of
every minute and like,
that's what friends do.
When we're together, a lot
of times we're not talking
every second, so all of
us breaking into our phone
and doing that, is what we used to do
when we collectively watched a show.
And yes, to your point,
maybe while we're watching
that wrestling match we'll
be like, that's funny, haha,
and have that collective,
but I do think that we're
over scrutinizing our behavior in this,
because the reality is, we always did.
People are like, oh, everyone's
painting a picture of their
best selves, and a PR
of themselves on social.
True, let me tell you
how that used to work.
You'd go outside and you'd
talk to your neighbor,
and they'd be like, how are things going?
You'd be like, oh phenomenal,
Ricky is going to be
fucking in NASCAR and
Susan is going to be on TV
and everything's great, meanwhile,
their fucking dad's an alcoholic.
We always front, all that
social media is doing
is exposing on digital
what we always were and do.
Thoughts, Charly?
- I think that you're correct
in the sense that yes,
we're all sitting in a room
and watching TV, that's fine
but people are on their
phones when they're
walking down the street,
people are on their phones
when they're in a restaurant--
- What do you want them to
do, look at a fucking tree?
- I mean, you miss everything
that goes by though.
Like, did you see that?
No, I'm sorry I was staring
at an Instagram picture
that I've already seen six times.
- Help me, see what, the
squirrel ate a fucking--
- Yes.
- I'd rather see fucking
WorldStar's premier of fucking
the new fucking Euro Gotit fucking video.
Let me tell you what you're
doing that I believe is
the most interesting human condition.
We put the past on a
pedestal and we fear monger
the current and future.
It's just what we do.
For example, this you will remember.
Remember how outrageous
what Miley Cyrus did
on the fucking MTV Music
Awards only seven, eight
summers ago, it was so outrageous?
That's like a lame Instagram post today.
- [Charly] Yeah.
- Yeah, everything gets elevated right.
- 100%, we are funny as a people.
Listen, I understand your point.
I genuinely think what's in
my phone is more interesting
than the fucking cloud shaped
like a fucking unicorn.
- Fair.
- And I think that we're demonizing it.
Here's the good news, you can
do whatever the fuck you want.
You wanna put your phone
in your fucking little
jean jacket here and look at,
oh look at what just happened,
a car goes by, knock yourself out.
But I think we're putting
things of the past on a pedestal
and my point is, humans
will pick what they want.
Humans do what they want to do.
So when I go out and see
a couple having dinner
and they're not both on
the phone, that tells me
that's not a good relationship.
Not, oh, I hate technology,
because I'm old enough
remembering going out
to dinner and did think
it was interesting that I
could sit next to a couple
and they wouldn't say a
fucking word to each other
the whole dinner.
And I didn't even understand
that because I'm a big
talker, my family is very
loving, now I'm like,
oh shit, to me weirdly when
I see people on the phone,
I think thank God we have
phones now where people
can do what they actually want to do.
- But do you ever find
yourself picking up your phone
and going on to Instagram,
let's say, and just scrolling
and it's mindless, you don't
even realize you're on it.
- Like watching TV or
going through fucking--
- [Charly] And you're like
wait, I've already seen all this
and I don't even know why I'm on it.
- Do you know how many
fucking times you went through
Vogue at 13 that you saw 900 times?
- Yeah.
- Thank you, I mean, we haven't changed.
You going through your
Instagram feed, you literally
went through fucking Seventeen
magazine like 900 times,
and guess what, that was the same shit.
- Yeah.
- Good news, Instagram's not.
What do you guys think
about this conversation?
Are you fear mongering technology?
Like you're clearly not, but--
- What, you think I'm on the edge or what?
- I don't know, I'm
excited to hear your truth.
- I'd probably have a
flip phone if I could.
- Right you love this,
like, I'm fucking outdoors,
fuck new technology,
like you're into that.
- Gotta keep that old school, new school.
- Like I'd rather go to a
lake and fucking shoot a deer,
like that, right?
- I do like that.
- I respect that, that's
where you've taken it
as an ideology.
- A little bit.
- What, if anything, do you
like about modern technology?
Netflix? Phones?
- It's convenient, I mean,
the convenience, right?
Directions anywhere, you can
go online, look anything up.
- I apologize to cut you off real quick.
By the way they love, who's
watching, when I cut people off.
They're literally, I
should never have guests on
any kind of show, it's the
only time my audience is like,
you're such a fucking dick,
just let somebody say something.
But I wanna say a story,
because I gotta get it off.
When I was a kid, unlike
you three fuckfaces,
when you wanted to meet
your friend after school,
it was like this kind of shit.
"Yo, all right, so 4:30 at
the fucking mall fountain."
And crazy shit would
happen like, you know,
a car accident would happen
somewhere and the person
would be late and you'd
go, well, I guess Josh
is not going to come and you just leave.
And the next day at school they'd be like,
"Yo where were you?"
This actually happened in the 90s.
Anyway, go ahead, you were
saying, it's kind of cool
that I have a phone now
so that I can use Waze
and get to the fucking place.
- Oh yeah, the convenience is great.
I don't like that it's
taken out, you know, you can
look up any answer
quickly, I don't know if I
necessarily like that all the time.
- Interesting, I can see
where you're going with that.
- Like everybody's smart.
- Yeah, I mean it kind of takes
away some general knowledge
things, like everybody's--
- Yeah, but then they're putting general
knowledge on a pedestal
and actually in that sense,
it was a commodity.
So you're going to the
place I'm very passionate
about with school.
I do not want to send my kids
to school to memorize shit
when the fucking answer's on their phone.
Like, what are you doing here?
- Like I was on the tip of
that when I was in school.
You could kind of look
stuff up right away, I mean,
we didn't have smart phones yet when I was
in that part of school.
- So what do you use, if
anything, now, nothing?
- Social media wise?
- Yeah.
- Oh I go on 'em all, like check 'em.
- For like personal use, like
looking at chicks and stuff?
- Yeah.
- I mean I understand.
- That's the other
problem with social media.
Relationships are never
going to be the same
because guys are like,
oh, look at this hot girl,
I'm going to DM her.
- Well good news, that's what guys
always did in the past too.
- But now these hot babes
are at their fingertips
and so they're like, eh,
you're all right but just
sitting next to me on the
couch in sweats, no makeup,
look at this girl with their tits out.
- But girls do that too.
- I don't think they do it like guys do.
- Right, they're like,
look, that guys looks
super well off and
doing his fucking thing.
I don't know if you know,
but it goes both ways.
(laughing)
You're all in.
- Yeah, I'm all in, I have
one small doubt of it,
obviously I have a child,
kids being on phones early.
I think there's a certain
level of learning how to
have a conversation,
look somebody in the eye,
that gets lost with throwing
an iPad in kids faces.
- Let's talk about this.
You know that your grandfather
has things like that
that you laughed out of the building.
Like to me, what's super
interesting is, and I mean this,
this is really smart talk,
not me trying to be funny.
Why does looking somebody in the eye
when you have a conversation,
why does that need to be
on a pedestal, because I'll
tell you as a historian
of communication, people
shit on the telephone
because the proper way to do it
was to write a proper letter.
Like, again, this is a
theme and I'm going to
bring it up again, it's
fascinating that we put
things in the past on
pedestals, and I think it's,
I'll be very honest, I'm
very different than that.
I have two young children, I
want my kids on screens 24/7.
I'm not kidding and let me tell you why.
What world do you think
they're going to live in?
- That world.
- 100%.
- It isn't going to go away.
- Just like watching film, or
getting in at like 13 or 15,
the reality is, here's what it
is, especially when you have
that nice little girl when she's one,
you go into protection mode
and you start getting worried.
Remember when MySpace was
going to get everybody
kidnapped at the mall?
Everybody goes to the negative
instead of the positive.
Let me give you a positive
that nobody talks about.
There are millions of children
right now, young adults,
who got into a high
school or a junior high,
where it didn't click, something happened.
The normal shit that we
all grew up with, right,
like the wrong person picked
on you, you liked somebody,
they broke up with you in a weird way
and something happened and your brand,
AKA your reputation, got affected.
And in the past you had nowhere to go.
The fact that that kid
could go home right now,
put on Twitch, and hang
out with his or her homies,
right, across the world, is so powerful.
Yet, we think social
media is bullying kids.
No no, kids are not being taught to lose,
so they don't know how
to deal with adversity,
so by the time they get to 14
when everybody just defaults
into being a dick for fucking survival,
and we were all there,
they're like, oh shit,
I don't know how to handle this.
Not, it's bullying, social
media has so much good to it
of people finding, if you're a
theater nerd, but you're not,
you're in the deep NASCAR
or NFL, but you can find
your whole tribe on
Instagram, it's very powerful
but we default into the
negative versus the positive.
Like looking somebody in
the eye, like, help me here.
I get it, saying you want
your kids to respect people,
that's different, as a
matter of fact, again,
I think obviously we have
a lot of issues in the air
in our society right now,
but I think the best way
for people to respect people
is to get to know about them
and I think that exposure
that the internet does
allows them the potential to respect.
It also allows them, if
they're misparented, to hate.
Anyway, I just think our
kids are going to live
in a massive technology world
where they're going to be
interacting with robots and I promise you,
every person listening
and everybody thinking
here right now this iPhone
and all the technology
is going to seem lame as fuck in 15 years
because the same way that
everybody who's listening
that grew up with a pager,
which was fucking crazy,
and you were a narc if you
had one, or a drug dealer,
you know, that is a
piece of shit now, right?
I just don't think you
can stop technology.
And I think I'm trying
to have this conversation
because I think that even at the young age
that you guys are at,
there's this quick trigger
to look at the negative of it, and I just
definitely believe that
life is about perspective,
delusion versus determination.
I do think that we need to
take a step back and realize
how much good is being
done because of this.
Because the world has never been better
when you look at the macro stats
of poverty, and everything,
health, everything, and all of it's
on the back of technology.
- So you would think it was not weird
if somebody, I'm stuck on this one,
looking someone in the eye.
You wouldn't think it was
weird if you were talking
to someone and they were
talking to you like this?
- But that's not what people do.
Nobody without a phone
in their hand, looks,
first of all, that's actually true.
Some people do not look you in
the eye because they're shy,
without a phone, I'm not
super affected by that.
Nor would I be affected if
I was talking to somebody
right now and they were
texting while I was talking.
Because I've done it as well
and I don't want to be a hypocrite.
And I also don't, I think people
have ego, way too much ego.
Like who the fuck are you
that somebody can't disrespect
you, like fuck you.
- What about a firm handshake?
Like if somebody gives you a--
- I like a firm handshake,
like I think it's--
- It's kind of along the same line.
- Yeah, I'll go, but I can
think of two guys right now,
who have two very firm handshakes
and they're fucking
soft and fucking losers.
So to me it's like, where
are we going with this
firm handshake because
both those guys are fucking
soft, they suck, they're
actually dicks, I have no respect
for them whatsoever,
their fucking handshakes
are fucking legit, and their
fucking jawline, tremendous.
- Oh they got that right then don't they.
- So listen, here's what I would say.
I don't want to shit on
tried and true and tradition.
I come from an Eastern
European background, I've got
a lot of things, but I
care about the essence
of what they meant.
You want to not look me in
the eye and not have the
firm handshake but be a
respectful awesome human being,
I fuck with you.
You see where I'm going?
I think we've transferred
that, those things we're
actually trying to say,
into these little things
and then we hold the
things on the pedestal.
- I agree.
- Where the intent, you
know, I really don't want
to go there but I'm going to go there,
it's why I'm fascinated by the kneeling
on the National Anthem thing.
I'm fascinated by how a
conversation can change
from what it is.
So that's how I think about things.
What's the point of looking
somebody in the eye?
- [Ty] Respect.
- Oh, Grandpa, you want
respect, I'm with you.
Respect matters, but the amount of people
that look you in the
eye and firm handshake,
and steal money in the back,
cheat on their girl in back,
do all this stuff, so what are
we talking about here, right?
So it's really interesting.
I just landed from London 40 seconds ago.
I watched, yeah, I'm
fucking super wired up.
Like a nine hour flight,
I'm nine hours ahead,
or like five hours or six hours ahead.
There was no WiFi, which is the weirdest.
When there's no WiFi my
whole world goes bonkers.
So, A, thank God I caught
up on all of my work,
because I use my inbox as
my work, and then I'm like,
fuck, I have time, so
maybe I'll watch a movie,
which is very rare for me to ever be off,
so I watched the Paterno
HBO movie, the Joe Paterno,
Joe Pa, right, respect,
tradition, 61 years, 45 coach.
And you know, I was watching,
this is super powerful,
the religion of college
football people reacted to
over the well being of 10
year old boys being raped
by a man.
And you know what's funny, I get it.
Because I don't want to be a
hypocrite, because guess what,
when it comes to the New York Jets,
I'm not a rational person.
- Who is your favorite
New York Jet all time?
- Al Toon.
- Really.
- I don't know if you know
who that is, he's old.
- Yeah.
- But he's my favorite,
Al Toon card up there,
it's right there behind
Randy The Macho Man Savage,
who is my favorite wrestler of all time.
- Why not Broadway Joe, man?
- Mainly because I didn't see him play.
I love the legend of Broadway
Joe, I love that he was
the coolest fucking dude of
all time and all that stuff.
But mainly on the back of
I just didn't see him play.
You're just so much more
affected by what you see played.
Let's do a little cross polination.
Did you know, in Indianapolis
racing, was it more
Formula One culture or, in
that whole sport, did you
care about NASCAR, did you care about--
- I mean, Indy Car was the
big dog in Indianapolis.
But I covered the Brickyard a few times.
- Were you a Danica fan?
- Yeah, of course--
- That must have been huge, right?
- Of course, she's a pioneer.
- Your age, yeah yeah.
- Oh yeah, for sure I
love Danica and I love
what she's in now and
just turning her career
into a much more encompassing thing.
- So that's your world.
I'm going to ask them about
their wrestling fandom,
or there not of.
- That was my wold, but I
mean NFL's my favorite sport.
- You're a Colts fan.
- Yeah, Colts fan.
- We'll talk about that in
a second, 'cause there's
two very hard core Jets Colts
playoff games of the last
decade that I want to talk
to you about, three actually,
in the last two decades.
Wrestling.
- I was into it big, I
think, mid-90's, when I was
probably eight to 12 years old.
- Same era, that whole
Stone Cold, or were you more
WCW, 'cause they're in the south?
- Like Sting and all
those guys, that was my,
and that was kind of like at the age
where my parents were like,
you probably don't need
to watch too much of this.
And I was like okay whatever,
I'm going to watch it.
I was all in for a while.
- Who is your favorite
wrestler of all time?
- I love Sting.
- Sting, he's a fucking
legend of course, huge.
Nothing.
- Not a big, no--
- Never?
- No, never got into it.
- Never got you.
So we're goin to a Lions
Jets game and I'm going to
take you to Summer Slam,
oh no, you're in season
during Summer Slam.
- Survivors, you guys still--
- It's in LA.
- Is that still Thanksgiving?
- Yeah, in late November.
- I was never big into wrestling or boxing
or anything like that.
I went to the Mayweather McGregor fight,
not wrestling, obviously.
- That was a cultural event.
You were into that?
- Yeah, it was awesome,
the atmosphere was great.
- Yeah, just being in Vegas.
- [Charly] Ronda Rousey's
with us now so maybe--
- That's right, I saw,
I didn't see the event.
That was Wrestlemania
where she popped out first?
- [Charly] Yeah.
- She got really good reviews.
- Yeah, she's great. She's
actually one of the most
humble, down to earth people
that I've come across.
You'd never guess that she
was just inducted into the
UFC Hall of Fame because she's super cool.
Just super down to earth, not like--
- She's trying to build her
respect in the game, right?
- [Charly] Yeah.
- So Randy Savage over Rick Flair,
I mean, I don't know a lot--
- I loved Rick Flair, I was
a northeast kid so I was
more of WWF than the NWA,
WCW, the stuff that was
going down south but I watched both a lot.
I used to love when one
would switch leagues
and just have a new
character, the whole thing.
That was always fun, this
was pre-internet so you
didn't know what was coming,
now you know everything.
Back then you'd just wake
up Saturday and be like,
oh fuck, Billy Jack Hayes is now here,
everybody'd be like so crazy.
- I have an old school one for ya.
- Thank you so much,
that's awesome, thank you.
This guy, when he first came, for example,
let's talk about the Ultimate Warrior.
I used to watch ESPN Houston,
like Texas wrestling,
where he was the Dingo
Warrior down in Texas
against the Von Erichs,
so when he came to the WWF
I could make that
connection, that was like,
I was really really
interested, I'm still like,
when the Hall of Fame event
was here, I'm still like,
I'm so busy I consume no
content, even the joke I made
about watching a movie,
I'm a little behind it,
but a lot of the WWE guys
are starting to DM me
on Instagram and it's super fun.
I'm trying to figure
out how to hack my time
to watch it a little more
because I want to get
back into it because a lot
of them are giving me love
which makes it fun.
- Which ones?
- Sheamus has hit me
up, Wyatt has hit me up.
So it's coming, and it's
super fun, like Rey Mysterio.
It's super fun.
- You a hockey fan?
- I grew up a huge Rangers fan.
Literally the reason we're
in my office right now,
and when we built this
office there's two corners,
the other one is a much
better view, like it's of
the Hudson, you can see the
fucking Statue of Liberty,
and look at Jersey, I'm
such a proud Jersey boy,
but the Nicks and Rangers, the Garden.
The '94 Rangers won me
my first championship
when I was 18 and I like
watched all four sports
since I was six, so like
48 seasons of losing,
Jets, Nicks, Rangers,
Yankees, because the Yankees
weren't good when I was a kid.
So I was a huge hockey fan.
- [Erik] I love hockey.
- Yeah, that's territory, right?
- [Erik] Red Wings.
- That's big, that's real religion.
- Red Wings are serious,
yeah, they're great games.
They're fun to go to.
- What can I answer
for you guys real quick
and then we'll bounce outta here.
Anything I can answer for you?
- For me, planning, looking
into the future always--
- Post driving?
- Yep, post driving.
- Like 35, 40, 45, those years?
- Yeah, 45, if I could make it to 45
it would be an awesome
career, but I don't want
to stop there, I want
to keep the path going
like the things I need to
do when I hang the helmet
up at 45, the next day I'm stepping into--
- So I think one thing that
social really works out
for all three of you
that I would tell you,
it's an answer for all three of you.
Become religious about the audience.
I think the thing that Vince
and the whole crew there
has done, and if you think
about when NASCAR does well
or doesn't do well, or
other sports do well
or don't do well, when I
think about my career and the
things we do at this
company for marketing,
I don't think people
care about the audience
enough at times.
They get caught.
It's not that they're
bad, it's that they get
into their own dynamics.
They go inside, they don't
become consumer centric.
I think if you keep
reading those comments,
keep engaging with it,
keep putting up content,
you'll be unbelievably stunned on how easy
the answers will come of what to do
because it's been said to
you in the trenches, got it?
What do you got Charly?
- I admire you because
your network is so huge
and I feel like everybody
is, oh, I've exchanged
a DM with Gary before,
oh I've seen him here.
It's like everybody knows
you and has had maybe some
type of interaction with you,
although it may be small,
but you just seem to be able
to create such a network
and keep it, whereas I feel
like I could meet someone
who I'm like, oh my god,
I met this girl yesterday,
she was awesome, I wanna
grab dinner with her,
and a week later I'm like,
oops, I forgot all about it.
- Like, who was that blonde?
- I don't even have that
many people in my life
but you have millions and
you manage to curate these
relationships with them and
keep them going and building
them and it's almost overwhelming to me.
- I think, much like anything
else, every one of us
does something that is
overwhelming to each other.
For me, people have always come natural.
It's funny, if you think about earlier,
10 minutes ago what I was
talking about with people interaction,
it's crazy because my love
in life is other people.
It's probably why I got
to, respect isn't the eye
or the shake, it's the truth, you know.
My truth is, I really like people.
And it starts with, closest
to the sun, like I would die
for my family and then out from that.
I think my employees
in here will tell you,
there's just a different
level of how I manage it,
I just like them more.
I don't know what else to really, it's not
super complicated, I want
to be admired and liked,
I like and admire them, I give
respect right off the bat,
you have to lose it, it's not
like you've gotta earn it,
it's that lack of ego that
I think, I have so much
confidence and bravado and
personality pours one way,
but I think in my actions
I really, the thing I'm
proud of is my ability to have humility,
because honestly, I think
everything I've done
yesterday back, it means nothing.
It's very weird, it really works for me.
I get it, I'm in the reverse,
I don't romanticize the back.
It's probably why I push
against this, I'm even like
psychoanalyzing myself right
now, I'm like, oh shit,
that makes sense.
I think people are 100%, the why of life.
Starting with the people
that come to your funeral.
Think about it, start with the end.
Like, who'd you compel enough that, like,
do you know why I think
going to a funeral is like
the most fascinating thing in society?
Because I'm surprised the
funerals I was willing
to not go to.
I'm being very real with everybody.
I'm fascinated by some
of the people that I did
business with, in the liquor business
over the last 20 years, I
was very young, I was a kid,
and like kind of like you know,
a generational family business.
I think it's very interesting, in a world
where we're all selfish
and doing our thing,
who's brought you so much
value that you'll just stop.
Obviously your family
members, but then what?
Like, right?
It's just super interesting.
I've basically been living my life
for a pretty long time now
on can I be so great that everybody stops
and comes to my funeral?
You know, it's funny,
I've always been like,
for a long time I never talked about it,
and then I talked about it, I'm like,
is that douchy, what is that?
Now I'm kind of like, I'm
super happy I'm like that.
It means I want to do the right thing
for the right reasons.
Not to make up what respect
and admiration and kindness is,
but the actual truth behind it.
So yeah, I value, and I'm
also grateful, you know,
I'm actually listening to all three of you
because of what you wanted
to do, there was always
a thought if you guys
became big time drivers,
if you got on television,
you knew that you would
have some level of fame.
Whether you dreamed about it,
for TV you dreamed about it,
for you, it could have been
a little bit different,
but you just knew you'd be known.
For me I always wanted
to be a business man.
And that didn't mean that
anybody would ever know you.
So for me, all this
attention came when I was
not looking for it and I
was well into my late 30s
when it became like, oh,
this is gonna get like,
I think I'm gonna be the next Oprah.
In like white dude form.
So there's a level of
gratitude that makes me,
the fact that people wanna know who I am
seems weird and amazing and all of that.
What do you got, bro?
- I think for me, I have probably a basic
question for you.
- [Gary] Cool, basic's good.
- We have so many sponsors
and so many people we're
trying to make happy and that's all right,
it's what makes our world go
'round, how do we support them
and show them on social media
without looking, cheese?
What they want, and what
I want to post is very--
- Your basic question is
actually the question,
so good job.
I think it's communication.
I think, first of all,
right now you're young
and the leverage you have
is different than say
a top five racer, 10, 15
years in with championships,
but it will always be communication.
I think, whether it's
your makeup at this young
of an age or when you have the leverage.
The right answer is,
hey, you're my sponsor.
You want me to do good for
you, I don't want to do
what you want me to do on social,
which then means it's
going to feel inauthentic,
which then means it's dead.
If I had never worn a pair
of K-Swiss when I was a kid,
I would never have done the collaboration.
Thank God, I mean this, this is not a joke
because I would have wanted
to, thank god I had one,
and I've been trying
to think and I've still
been battling with my head,
I'm trying to find Andy,
Andy Greco, if you're watching this,
sixth grade when you wore those
weird red sneakers with
leafs on them and I made
fun of you and I apologize for that,
did I have K-Swiss or was that Adidas?
I need your help on that
because I can't remember.
But I definitely remember the one K-Swiss
tennis sneakers I had.
I think authenticity matters.
Now you don't have say the way that I do,
and so you've got a sponsor
too that maybe isn't
your favorite power
drink or what have you.
What I think it is, is authenticity.
One, I think you need to be posting
what you want to be posting.
Obviously you need to be able to deal
with the ramifications,
like if you say things
that are not going to fly
you'll have to deal with that.
But I think when you're
obligated to do a post,
like, ready, Macho Man's
my favorite wrestler.
If I had to post this I
would do some sort of post
that'd be like a weird
face, and in my copy
I'd be like, here's my
Ultimate Warrior story.
Number one, when he beat Macho Man,
I fucking hated him for it.
Number two, I loved him as
the Dingo Warrior in his
battles with Rick Rude in the Texas League
that later went to the,
like, I would tell the truth.
And so that's, you know,
there's people in sports
that are being represented
or have sponsorship deals
with a product that they, for
example, we work with Pepsi,
and I told Pepsi, and
say it loud right now,
they're currently a multi
million dollar client,
I grew up drinking Coke.
I just think the truth
is always the leverage.
My K-Swiss deal, my
sneaker deal, almost died
because in the clause I would not sign
that I would only wear K-Swiss
even though they give me
millions of dollars.
- They make the tubes?
K-Swiss, is that them?
- What's that, the tubes?
- [Erik] Yeah, the shoes,
with tubes on the bottom.
You know what I'm talking about?
- No, I'm trying to think though.
I don't think so, what are the tubes?
- [Erik] Like little circles, you know,
on the bottom of the shoe.
- Oh, the Air, I think that's Nike.
You mean the little lift,
I think that's Nike,
right, the Air?
- No no no.
- [Ty] I think it's K-Swiss.
- You're thinking of something else?
Okay we'll look at it after.
Yeah, he's talking about those circles
that are like this, right?
Yeah these, right?
- Yeah, yeah, that's K-Swiss.
- You have those?
- No I don't have those.
- You want some?
- [Erik] Yeah sure.
- Awesome, we've done
a lot of business here.
Jets Lions, Survivor Series,
fucking K-Swiss with the tubes.
- [Ty] We'll just go home.
- Guys thank you so so so
much for being on the show.
Everybody that's watching,
follow these three,
support their careers.
Thank you again.
- Thank you so much.
(electronic music)